good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
an exclusive report this morning on
alleged ammunition for Russia's war in
Ukraine a Security Source tells us about
the ships from Iran carrying bullets and
shells to Russia we'll speak to Ukraine
Ambassador also this morning the UN
Refugee agency says it's profoundly
concerned about the government's new
laws to crack down on small boats
migration would be joined by the Home
Secretary of Zola bravaman and her labor
Shadow Yvette Cooper it's Wednesday the
8th of March
Sky News learns Iran has secretly
supplied a large quantities of
ammunition To Russia for the war in
Ukraine we track the ships accused of
replenishing moscow's stocks
and the PM insists that the new laws to
stop migrants crossing the channel are
tough but fair but the U.N Refugee
agency claims it's effectively a ban on
Asylum
a warning of severe disruption this
morning with more snow and ice expected
as the UK is hit by an Arctic blast
hope of a rail strike breakthrough the
rmt union suspends industrial action
against Network rail after a new
payoffer
the NHS approves a new weight loss
injection which can help people reduce
their weight by 10 percent
the legacy of the lionesses on
International women's day the government
makes good on promises made to the euro
22 winners for equal access to school
sports
[Music]
hello everybody a very good morning to
you we want to start with an exclusive
report uh security sources told Sky News
that Iran has secretly supplied large
quantities of bullets rockets and mortar
shells to Russia for the war in Ukraine
and plans to send still more The Source
said to Russian flagged cargo ships
departed an Iranian port in January
Bound for Russia via the Caspian Sea
carrying about a hundred million bullets
and around 300
000 shells we want to get more
information on that it's an exclusive by
our defense and security editor Deborah
Haynes good mornings good to see you
this morning tell me more yeah so this
source told me about these alleged
shipments by Iran to Russia that Russia
paid for these ammunition rounds in cash
and that it used it comprised a whole
range of different types of bullets
different sizes for um from for pistols
and assault rifles machine guns to
mortars grenade launchers rocket
launchers the full panopoly it's
important to say that we haven't had a
response from the Russian government nor
from the Iranians but I was speaking to
the Ukrainian Ambassador yesterday he
said he's not surprised by these claims
he says he expects more because Russia
is having to use up so much of its
ammunition in this war in Ukraine which
is going on Russia's defense industry is
being hit by Western sanctions making it
harder to produce more which is why it's
turning to these allies and I know you
have a special report especially for
breakfast here we go
Russia is burning through ammunition in
Ukraine it means Russian industry is
under pressure to produce more
now claims have emerged that Moscow is
also receiving help from a close Ally
a source alleges that two ships
transported a large amount of ammunition
in January from Iran to Russia paid for
in cash
the security source told me the two
ships are thought to have been carrying
up to a hundred million bullets and
around 300 000 shells of varying sizes
for different weapons like machine guns
grenade launchers mortars it's not been
possible independently to verify the
volume and one expert said it did sound
quite high but Iran is certainly
suspected of supplying an amount of
ammunition To Russia to help replenish
stockpiles that are thought to be
running low
Sky News is data and forensics unit
looked into the movement of the two
Russian ships that were named by the
source as the Musa Jalil and the bege
on the 9th of January marine traffic
data show them in the Iranian Port of
amiribad on the Caspian Sea
this satellite image is taken the
following day
one of the ships the Musa Jaleel seen
here is likely turning to leave the port
later the other ship beg a and now Musa
Jalil appear to have left and are
traveling north towards the Russian
Coast
by the 27th of January they've reached
the Russian Port of Astra Khan the
vessels can be seen here and here in
this satellite image taken on the 2nd of
February
Sky News hasn't been able independently
to verify what they were carrying
Ukraine's ambassador to the UK says he's
not surprised about the ammunition
claims given that Iran is already
supplying Russia with deadly drones
this is a sort of a collision of of the
weak Nations trying to you know to
consolidate their last efforts to
withstand the pressure of much bigger
Western support which Ukraine is is
quite happy to have
but President Vladimir Putin is still
talking tough as his military fights on
asked about the ammunition claims
Russia's defense Ministry and Iran's
foreign Ministry have yet to give a
response
I suppose a big question Deborah is what
does this then mean going forward as far
as China is concerned that's the
question that many Western capitals are
asking and looking at the US has come
out publicly and Declassified
intelligence saying that they believe
China is considering sending weapons to
Russia for its war in Ukraine um there's
been no confirmation that that's
happened Beijing has denied these claims
but I was talking to officials about
this in recent days and they see this as
potentially this would be potentially
game changing should it happen given
that sustaining the war effort is so key
the Western allies are having to
struggle and scramble to keep
replenishing the Ukrainian stocks the
same is true for Russia at the moment
the stocks are running low but if China
steps in with its huge military Arsenal
um that that could be decisive
potentially and it's why people are
trying to stop that from happening okay
we've got the Ukrainian Ambassador on
the program later on this morning for
now thanks very much indeed thank you
well the Kremlin is this morning
questioning a report that U.S
intelligence believe a pro-ukraine group
was behind the attack on the Nordstrom
gas pipelines you remember back in
September the undersea explosion seven
months into the Ukraine war ruptured
pipelines running from Russia and
Germany the New York Times says U.S
officials believe the pro-ukraine group
acted without the involvement of
Ukraine's government a Kremlin
spokesperson says America can't assume
anything without proper investigation
and as I said at 9 30 we'll be joined by
Ukraine's ambassador to the UK that in
pristaico
foreign
Minister will face MPS for the first
time today after setting up plans for a
new law to try to tackle Small Boat
Crossings in the channel the new
legislation has been widely criticized
both at home and indeed overseas with
the U.N Refugee agency saying it's
profoundly concerned let's take a look
at the illegal as it's described
migration bill in a bit more detail it
would legislate a legal Duty for the
Home Secretary to remove anyone entering
the UK illegally the bill allows the
Detention of illegal arrivals without
judicial review for 28 days or until
they can be removed in 2021 the UK had
just over two and a half thousand
detention places that Set current levels
of migration less than 20 percent of the
capacity needed migrants won't be able
to use modern slavery laws to stop their
removal
any challenges will only be heard after
they have left the UK the Home Secretary
told MP she would not yet address a full
legal complexities of the bill
an annual cap on the number of refugees
being accepted by the UK will be decided
by MPS in Westminster migrants arriving
by illegal routes risk a permanent ban
on settlement citizenship and re-entry
to the UK well shiman is standing by for
as in Dover this morning so we chatted
yesterday morning we have a clearer idea
of what the government is planning this
morning don't we good morning to you
thank you
yes we have a much clearer idea of of
what the government is planning but not
much detail and how it will be
implemented however the government says
that these tough this tough new law is
needed to clamp down on those using the
small boats Crossing so this is of
course because there's been a huge
increase in the amount of people that
use this way of accessing the country
it's gone from around 300 in 2018 to 45
000 as of last year and this is why the
government says they are introducing
this they say they've tried everything
else and it hasn't worked however the
opposition the labor party have actually
blamed the government they've accused
the government of trying to blame others
over the illegal immigration issue
saying that it's actually the government
that have allowed the criminal gangs to
take hold of the channel and the border
and the UN they've also backed up this
uh this concern as well they've said
that they are concerned strongly
concerned by the plans and it would
effectively amount to a ban on Asylum
they said the current legislation which
was obviously introduced yesterday or
was announced yesterday would eradicate
the rights for those to seek refuge and
protection in the UK as I say the
government says that in order for them
to be able to put these safe and legal
routes in place they first need to crack
down on these small boats Crossings and
the illegal gangs that often prey on the
people trying to come over here so it
indeed there will be lots of questions
for Richard soon after answer later
today in the Commons okay for now thank
you
add in just a few moments time joined by
the woman of the moment the Home
Secretary Suella bravaman
um that coming up at 20 past seven uh
before that we want to hear from you
this morning labor says the government
is breaking the law in order to stop
people seeking Asylum here in the UK
what do you think you can tweet me
directly if you would like to at Cape
early so basically
labor says that the government is
breaking the law in order to get this
through Parliament what do you think do
you think that the government should be
in a position to be able to stretch the
law to its boundaries in order to make
sure that migrants cannot come to the UK
and if they do they will be sent back
straight away or do you feel that we
should have more compassion as a nation
your thoughts love to hear from you at
cabooly and we will share your thoughts
with the world a little bit later on
an Arctic blast is intensifying bringing
sleet and snow across England and Wales
and snow and hail showers to Scotland a
number of national severe warnings for
snow and ice have been issued and the
Met Office says Northern rural
communities are likely to be cut off
over the next day or two our weather
presenter Kirsty McCabe is joining us
now from Snowy sorry it certainly is
good morning Kirsty
[Laughter]
good morning Kay yes we've not had much
snow in Surrey this winter but we've got
some right now and across many parts of
Southern England parts of Wales southern
Ireland as well waking up to quite an
awkward wintry mix of rain sleet and
snow so near the coast it's pretty much
rain head in land and head to higher
elevation then you can see snow and
that's the problem in this country of
course is that we really have such a
fine boundary between whether we get
rain or snow as temperatures hover
around that freezing point so for some
it's not looking great this morning
although it's quite pretty to look at
the snow it does cause lots of problems
on the roads the rails and for some
schools shutting as well across Northern
Scotland there are a few areas they've
had issues with snow already this week
but this slushy mix of ice and snow on
the roads could make some quite tricky
traveling conditions this morning it
will melt through the day of course as
temperatures rise but freeze again
tonight so there's a myriad of weather
warnings out there throughout the next
few days we'll continue to see quite
frequent snow and Hill showers affecting
Northern Scotland but elsewhere it's a
bit more more interesting today we've
got this mix of rain season snow across
Southern parts of the UK and Ireland
that's moving its way eastwards by
around lunchtime and then another pulse
comes in from the West for this
afternoon this evening and then more
rain sleet and snow moving Northwest
through Thursday so we'll all see some
wintry weather through the next few days
okay lovely thank you looking at those
pictures from Scotland I'm sure that's
where they filmed one of the Bond movies
I'm sure it is people in Scotland
watching this morning correct me if I'm
wrong
um be good to hear from you as always
meantime the rmt union has suspended all
industrial action at Network rail
following a new payoffer industrial
action was due to take place next
Thursday but the walkout has been called
off although strikes by workers at 14
train operators are still scheduled to
go ahead Sky News understands talks are
ongoing between unions and the health
secretary and will continue today Nurses
and other health professionals had been
striking overpay and working conditions
the sister of one of the Cardiff car
crash victims says she was disappointed
with the police response to the incident
saying detectives should have acted
straight away when they were reported
missing over the weekend
what's up
[Applause]
yesterday a video was held in Cardiff to
remember the three young victims
fireworks were LED off to pay tribute
while crowds of people gathered with
balloons flowers and messages of
condolence Eve Smith Darcy Ross and
Rafael Jean died in the crash while
Sophie Russon and Shane Lachlan are in
hospital with critical injuries an
investigation has been launched into two
police forces over claims they failed to
begin a search with the victims quickly
enough they'd been reported missing when
they disappeared after a night out on
Saturday
now it's the second day of the parole
hearing for Britain's most notorious
prisoner Charles Bronson is expected to
start with evidence from an independent
psychologist commissioned by Bronson's
legal team during the first day of the
hearing on Monday he told the board he
was almost an angel now compared with
his old self
the 70 year old spent nearly five
decades in prison and says he wants to
get out to see his 95 year old mum
the trial of the man accused of shooting
dead Olivia Pratt called Bell in
Liverpool last summer continues this
morning yesterday prosecutors told the
court the nine-year-old screamed Mom I'm
scared moments before a bullet struck
her chest
Olivia was killed last August to us a
gunman chased a convicted burglar into
her home and mother Cheryl was injured
in the shooting
a statement was read in court on behalf
of Cheryl Corbell it reads I was just
screaming to go away and then I heard
the gunshot and realized because I felt
it it hit my hand she referred to Olivia
as the baby and said I remember when I
turned around and realized the baby was
right behind me because she'd come
obviously come down the stairs because
she'd heard
one of the other children heard Cheryl
scream Olivia had been hit
on the stairs she told Olivia Stay With
Me Baby
in other news the match of the day host
Gary lineker will be spoken to by the
BBC after appearing to compare the
government's Asylum policy to Nazi
Germany writing on Twitter the
ex-footballer criticized the bill as
immeasurably cruel and said the language
in which the plans had been set out was
not dissimilar to that used by Germany
in the 1930s
so Graham Brady has become the latest
prominent conservative MP to announce he
won't be standing at the next general
election is best known as the long-time
chair of the 1922 backbench committee
which has been Central to the ousting of
the last three prime ministers
at least six Palestinians have been
killed and dozens more have been injured
in an Israeli Army raid in the occupied
West Bank City of Janine the military
said that one of those killed in the
Junaid refugee camp was the suspected
assailant behind a fatal shooting of two
brothers in the northern West Bank Town
of hawari last week
Studies have found that the job for
weight loss saw people's weight drop by
12 percent on average after 68 weeks
going to tell you more about what we're
talking about with that basically it's
an injection that you can have which may
well be available on the National Health
Service and it means that you can lose
up to 12 of your body weight
okay let's bring more details now I
should read about the small boats that
we have been talking about lucky to have
the Home Secretary in the studio for us
this morning good morning to you thank
you so much for joining us
um as a barrister are you completely
comfortable with breaking the law
we're not breaking the law okay uh we
are very confident that our measures
that we've announced yesterday are in
compliance with our international law
obligations uh but it's really important
to know that we need to take action the
status quo is unacceptable uh 45 000
people arrived here illegally sometimes
fatally so last year I wasn't small
boats wasn't illegal it's breaking our
laws to come here without a legal basis
without permission and passing through a
safe country where they should have and
could have claimed a sign let me tell
you amnesty Internationals so they say
the rights of migrants refugees and
Asylum Seekers are protected by
international law regardless of how and
why they arrive in a country they have
the same rights as everyone else plus
special or specific protections
um as a barrister your condoning
breaking the law according to Amnesty
International we're not breaking the law
and no government representative has
said that we're breaking the law in fact
we've made it very clear that we we
believe we're in compliance with all of
our International obligations for
example the refugee convention the
European conventional human rights other
other conventions to which we are
subject but what's important is that we
do need to take uh compassionate but
necessary and fair measures now because
there are people who are dying to try
and get here they are breaking our laws
they are abusing the generosity of the
British people and we now need to ensure
that they are deterred from doing that
we need to break the model of the people
smuggling Gams we need to stop people
making this journey in the first place
if they want to come to the United
Kingdom they should choose to come here
through safe and legal routes they
should put in an application through the
legal they're not breaking the laws
they're not breaking the law the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
you just quoted that it states that
everyone has the right to seek and enjoy
Asylum from persecution in other
countries that's what they do well we we
have a very generous regime of
supporting people coming here lawfully
for humanitarian protection whether it's
the 150 000 ukrainians whether it's the
hundred thousand people from Hong Kong
Afghanistan Syria in many instances we
accept people who've come here lawfully
for those very purposes that you've just
referred to what we can't go on
accepting is people breaking our laws
jumping the queue I'm afraid you're
wrong they are coming here unlawfully
because they are they don't have a legal
basis to be here we're going to be
changing the law to ensure that they
don't make the journey in the first
place if they come here illegally they
come here on a small boat without a
legal basis to be here having passed
through a safe country through which
they should in which they should have
first claimed Asylum they won't be able
to settle here they won't be able to
claim Asylum here either they have an
entitlement to a life in the UK you have
talked about stretching the absolute
boundaries haven't you of of what is and
isn't legal that's like being a bit
pregnant you're either breaking the law
or you're not
um and according to all of the research
that we have done people who get on a
small boat to ride to the UK are not
breaking the law it's those that smuggle
them here that are breaking the law what
are you doing about them well on that
last point we can definitely agree I I
won't repeat that the first point the
people smuggling gangs are a root cause
of this problem and they are
sophisticated they are operating on an
international scale they are well
resourced and they are exploiting people
they are selling a lie they are
encouraging people to pay sometimes tens
of thousands of pounds sometimes they're
life savings in the vain hope that
they're going to travel here in a boat
and get a life in the UK that must be
smashed that model muscle what are you
broken well we are doing extensive work
with the National Crime agency to smash
these gangs and that's why I'm very
pleased that we've had hundreds of uh
arrests and convictions we've had
several uh gangs which have been shut
down I went out with the National Crime
agency a few months ago where they were
actually able to arrest uh very early in
the morning uh a people Smuggler who had
been part of these people came across on
the boats last year so it's not very
effective isn't it is it and we spoke to
a Smuggler here on Sky News as you know
who said that three-quarters of the
Smugglers are based here in the UK
you're absolutely right that it's not
acceptable that these gangs proliferate
and continue to operate in the way that
they do that's why we're also working
with the French to intercept the uh the
departures to share intelligence to
prevent the uh the successful operation
by these criminal Enterprises not that
effective at the moment but let's see
we've only had that's why when will the
new detention centers be open for
business
well we already have a detention
we are uh we are on the port we are
rolling out new detention spaces to
support when the detention pressures I'm
not going to give precise dates because
uh we will have uh you know we've got uh
logistical uh challenges that we're
always overcoming but very very soon
we'll be expanding our detention
capacity to meet the uh the the need uh
brought about by okay when will the
first failed Asylum Seekers be deported
again I can't give you precise dates I'm
afraid we have lots of do you have any
processes which are in train uh the uh
the processing of these people
well we have uh well you I mean we
already have an asylum caseload which is
being worked through very effective well
we're doubling
um the number of case workers to over 2
000 uh by over 2000 uh to process the
Asylum decisions which are waiting uh
within the home office 160 000 people
are the backlog of 160 000 people and
yet you still think that you can process
people within 28 days well that is
exactly why we've got to introduce the
measures and some of our measures will
put strict time limits on the uh on the
time within which people make their
legal claim and we will be employing
we are employing more staff already
we're doubling the number of Asylum
caseworkers already to Bear Down on our
Asylum backlog and we're making good
progress in that respect we're
increasing our productivity we're
streamlining our process is absolutely
vital that we bear down on that hundred
thousand uh but you taste it that are
waiting for a decision we've now
introduced new measures and new
procedures they are going to be it will
all depend on when this bill becomes an
act of parliament when we've now
introduced we're going to go through the
process in Parliament I encourage all of
my colleagues to support this bill so
that we get these powers on the statute
book as quickly as possible be sent to
Rwanda well again we are now we are part
of our Rwanda scheme is in court we had
a very strong victory in the high court
at the end of last year people will be
testing the lawfulness of our Rwanda
scheme I should just say you know about
12 months ago people were deriding
arawanda schemas being unlawful nobody's
the high court disagreed with that yeah
and we have to uh respect we have to
respect the court timetables so when
will they be sent to Rwanda where we we
will be going into an appeal hearing in
April relating to the Rwanda scheme we
will then await a judgment from the
course of appeal you'd have to ask the
Judiciary as to when the timetable how
much we will respect any timetable set
by the time how much would it cost per
removal
well we have uh paid a sum we I'm very
proud to Rwanda but more generally how
much will it cost per removal well at
the moment it's costing six million
pounds a day how much you want to
support the Asylum Seekers who are being
housed in hotel accommodation and the
premise of your question is that this is
somehow going to cost more no no I
completely reject that and what I'm
saying
I'm looking for some facts and I haven't
got a lot how much will it cost for well
I'll tell you what we'll save we'll save
three billion pounds a year if we get
this uh Bill onto the statute books if
we're able to relocate people to Rwanda
and if we're able to stop the boats okay
let me tell you that Mo Farah was
traffic when he was nine you probably
know this he's one of six gold Olympic
medals um under your new scheme he would
have been deported when he was 18.
is that the case well as I said we we
are very proud of our world leading
modern slavery uh is that is that regime
just let me just answer your question
please and we've got uh world-leading
protections on human trafficking we're
signatories to the European convention
against trafficking and I'm very proud
of the legislation that this government
or the conservative government put in
place to protect victims of trafficking
and modern slavery uh that that those
arrangements are in place and people who
are genuine victims of trafficking or
modern slavery can claim protection in
the UK many thousands two of them do
what we don't want is the illegitimate
we're gonna have to let it go I know I'm
out of time but do you acknowledge that
Mo Farah a nine-year-old Mo Farah would
have been booted out of the country when
he was 18. no I don't acknowledge that I
think we have very lawful roots for
people who are genuine victims of
trafficking or modern slavery and for
them to access protection I'm very proud
of that tradition and that culture and
that provision in this country tree a
long way that continued what we've got
to stop is the abuse of our generosity
okay and just to underline you're not
sure at this stage when the first person
will be told that they'll be taken out
of the country under your new laws our
new laws are going to make sure that
we'll have the power to but you detain
and remove people and we're very
confident about moving forward with our
groundbreaking partnership with the
Rwanda I must let you go it's good of
you to join us this morning thank you
very much and thank you thank you quick
look at what the papers are saying in
just a moment but I do want to tell you
that Mark Voyager a former advisor to
the Commanding General of U.S army
Europe about our exclusive report on
Iran allegedly it's supplying ammunition
To Russia will be joining us uh we'll
also be speaking to a woman who was
misdiagnosed with endometriosis for over
a decade as scientists launched a
clinical trial for potential new
treatment and that will be coming up
momentarily before that the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
Northerly flow making its very cold
widespread overnight Frost milder air
preceded by snow and rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
turn now for a look through some of the
photos that have caught our eye today
contestants for this year's crafts
competition have arrived in Birmingham
ahead of day one of the event which
kicks off tomorrow the annual
International dog show is the largest of
its kind in the world and sees pups from
all over compete for various awards for
the top prize being Best in Show some of
the pooches made up yesterday for a
photo call ahead of the competition this
is Harlequin called H for short and that
is a Chihuahua called boo which is me
and which is the home secretary's son
might ask
in addition to that we've got you
remember we had three doggies on the
program earlier on in the month in fact
at the end of last month they will also
be at Cross I love that picture also on
the program for you still to come the
lionesses helps secure the Legacy by
equaling access to sport in school
foreign
[Music]
let's tell you more about the lionesses
talked about then before the break
they've helped to secure their Legacy by
equaling access to sport in school to
Mark International women's day the
government has announced a new package
of measures to ensure boys and girls
have equal access to two hours a week of
school sport in school it comes after
England's lionesses Squad launched a
campaign
urging the government to pass measures
to ensure that all girls get the chance
to play football at school following
their Euros win last summer good for
them looking at our top stories for you
this morning now Sky News has learned
that Iran has secretly Supply supplied
forgive me large quantities of
ammunition To Russia for the war in
Ukraine we track the chips accused of
replenishing moscow's stocks
the Prime Minister says he's up for the
fight against critics of new legislation
to stop migrant Crossings as the U.N
Refugee agency calls it a clear breach
of international law we just had the
Home Secretary on the program and she
disagrees the weather is pretty bad as
well as you can see
tomorrow is joining us this morning oh
actually should we hear what uh the
swella Braven had to say first of all
tomorrow and then we will come back to
you I asked her whether she's
comfortable that she's not breaking the
law with new government plans to tackle
illegal migration as she put it
we're not breaking the law and no
government representative has said that
we're breaking the law in fact we've
made it very clear that we believe we're
in compliance with all of our
International obligations for example
the refugee convention the European
conventional human rights uh other other
conventions to which we are subject but
what's important is that we do need to
take uh compassionate but necessary and
fair measures now because there are
people who are dying to try and get here
they are breaking our laws they are
abusing the generosity of the British
people
as I said tomorrow is here the UN and
Amnesty International disagree they say
that she is breaking the law and indeed
few people in government wouldn't
concede that there are going to be big
legal and practical obstacles to
bringing in this bill in fact just
looking at the bill that the Home
Secretary introduced to Parliament
yesterday it says on the front page of
it that she's unable to say that this is
compatible with the European convention
on human rights normally the government
would say which bits of international
law is affected by the laws they're
passing she says she's unable to say
that because then the government aren't
100 sure whether it is compatible with
international law which she's very
full-on that's very much so and the
Prime Minister yesterday when asked said
that effectively that the government
would try very hard to defend it in
court I wonder if that will make some
MPS and peers in the House of Lords
where this is likely to be held up a bit
jittery about it the fact that the
government has not made sure this is 100
compatible with international law they
clearly are prepared to go and fight out
in the court another big question is of
course how this is going to work on the
ground because the suggestion is that
people who come via the Channel with
within work will within 28 days be sent
back to either Rwanda if they can get
that up and running or their own country
or another safe country and there are
thousands of people coming every day and
currently there isn't the detention
capacity as you also ask the Home
Secretary about and also the suggestion
that only children under 18 and the most
vulnerable people will be able to stay
it may not be something that is going to
work legally because of course you
pointed out the case of Mo Farah and the
Home Secretary said he would have
protection under our trafficking and
modern slavery laws when actually the
Prime Minister said yesterday he hoped
to stop people claiming under those yeah
indeed so the questions I suppose that
we wanted to know the answer to would
have included
um how much is it going to cost when are
the first people going to go when will
they be going to Rwanda and we didn't
seem to get any answers to any of those
few answers on any of those conservative
MPS have been asking those kind of
questions as well I don't think there's
much doubt this is going to stop proceed
through the comments they're having a
vote on first vote on it next Monday the
government are hoping to get it passed
they tell me by the summer but I think
there's going to be a lot of legal
obstacles in the way and this is going
to end up being fought out in court as
to whether this can actually go ahead
get it through the House of Commons can
you get it through the courts
let's see uh meantime Sky News has been
told that Iran has supplied large
quantities of ammunition and military
equipment to Russia for its war in
Ukraine a Security Source says two
Russian flagships left an Iranian port
in January with cargo that included a
hundred million bullets and 300 000
shells let's get some more reaction on
that should be joining us is Mark Borger
former special advisor for Russia and
Eurasian Affairs to the Commanding
General of U.S army Europe thank you so
much for joining us on the program this
morning it's good to see what do you
make of the news that Iran is sending
Munitions to Russia
well good morning Kay um thank you for
having me always a pleasure what has
transpired what has been revealed risk
clearly demonstrates that both Iran and
Russia have entered a sort of a de facto
Alliance and I would call it an Unholy
League of undemocratic regime
that are quite similar in their
International actions uh also in the way
they operate in their regions and the
way they treat their people uh on and at
the Diplomatic level they are
effectively considered
their neighbors are very resentful and
Afraid and ultimately domestically this
technical issues I'm so sorry uh Mr
Voyager we we're not really able to
catch a lot of what you're saying at the
moment we're going to re-establish
communication with you and come back to
you very shortly indeed and my apologies
for that meantime in other news the
number of people using illegal cannabis
to self-medicate has increased by almost
30 since 2019 according to new research
it was legalized for medical purposes
five years ago but people living in the
UK continue to use the illegal cannabis
to gain access to the drug the market
that is Alice spoke to one medicinal
cannabis user and sent this report
um the dried Leaf is put into the top
here
like that switch it on and when it
comes to temperature they're nice simply
and ready to inhale from here for over
three decades Chris Cowan took cannabis
illegally to manage his depression and
PTSD I mean really it's potluck with the
type of cannabis that you get when
you're buying illicit cannabis
um
you don't know the quality or the
strength of it so there would be times
where I would take the illicit cannabis
and it would actually exacerbate my
symptoms Chris is now one of the 30 2
000 people in the UK who take medical
cannabis
for a prescription patients have to
receive a medical diagnosis and show
evidence that they've tried other
treatments the difference is is huge
it's still the same plant but it's very
very different to the illicit cannabis
that you get the first thing that I
noticed is that it alleviate my symptoms
right away it doesn't get me high it
doesn't intoxicate me in fact it does
the opposite research commissioned by
Sapphire medical clinics who specialize
in cannabis treatments suggest a quarter
of the public are unaware that medical
cannabis can be prescribed a 1.8 million
people are treating themselves for a
medically diagnosed condition with
cannabis on the illicit Market I think
that's just the figure itself is
something that took us by surprise when
we saw it
GPS can't prescribe medical cannabis
they need to make a referral but some
are unconvinced that it can treat such
wide-ranging conditions it appears to
work for those with intractable epilepsy
and it also appears to work for certain
conditions in multiple multiple
sclerosis but cannabis is now being
proposed for a whole host of other
conditions from Pain to anxiety to
depression so the main problem is that
we need to get a research base while
medical cannabis may continue to be
controversial for patients like Chris
it's life-changing
Alice Porter Sky News
check this out video emerging of a
passenger on a United Airlines flight
threatening to kill every man on this
plane before attacking a flight
attendant what's a lot about the man
tried to stab a flight attendant with a
broken metal spoon on a flight from Los
Angeles to Boston before that he
attempted to open the plane's emergency
door the 33 year old was arrested when
the plane landed in Boston United
Airlines said no one was injured in the
incident
I want to tell you about a new study now
which is found one in 10 women with
endometriosis suffer in silence March is
dedicated to endometriosis awareness a
condition where tissue similar to the
lining of the womb grows in places it
shouldn't causing excruciating pain and
in some cases infertility scientists are
now launching a clinical trial that if
successful could provide the First new
treatment for the condition in 40 years
let's get more about this should we form
a model and founder of the endometriosis
Foundation Carla Cressi is with us hi
Carla it's great to see you thanks for
joining us
tell me about endometriosis so it is
probably one of the most under
recognized as misunderstood under
diagnosed conditions and as you said it
affects one in ten often in silence I
was diagnosed when I was 25 but my
symptoms started when I was 13. I was
already under a Gynecology at 14 but
nobody knew you know what was wrong or
could kind of piece together why this
was happening so I went through this
kind of 10-year back and forth to the GP
to hospital
um and my diagnosis really only came
around because I was
um it was suspected that I had acute
appendicitis so I had my appendix
removed and we realized it wasn't that I
was still really unwell
um and then I was kind of taken back
into surgery and had open surgery where
they found stage four which is the very
end stage of endometriosis and it had
spread to my kind of bladder and my
bowel
um so yeah it's been quite a long kind
of Journey to get to my diagnosis and
back then end of which it was nowhere to
be seen on the internet so there was no
kind of information or awareness as to
what there is now but it's still just
lacking so much so what sort of symptoms
should young women watching this morning
what should they be looking out for
pelvic pain painful periods kind of
maybe changes in menstrual flow it can
be so different for each person
painful bladder and bowel movements
painful sex and also difficulties
getting pregnant but also it can depend
where it is in the body because it can
really travel anywhere in the body so
the type of symptoms that you might have
so for example if it's affecting the
bladder you might experience you know
extreme pain passing bladder movements
or unable to empty the bladder so yeah
it really can just depend on where where
it is and it's very debilitating I'm
guessing absolutely do you when you went
to the GP they didn't know what was
going on they didn't know so what if
other women go to the GP what do they
need to say in order to try to to think
this might be endometriosis and you need
to test for this we'll keep in a record
of symptoms can be really helpful um
just having something on paper and also
reaching out to Community Support boots
and kind of speaking to others going
through it as well because we are all so
different
and chances are you will come across
somebody else who's going through very
similar to you and just writing down
questions asking questions referring to
the nice guidelines which I believe are
in review at the moment
um and you know just going on that
referral pathway and just making sure I
miss it one in ten but I personally I
think it's a lot more because so many
people find it so difficult to get get
diagnosed so I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if it was at least one in six
one in seven right that's a lot of women
isn't it and and it could affect your
fertility yes so for me I was diagnosed
with stage four but it had progressed to
Frozen pelvis disease my but I also
ovarian endometriosis as well so I would
have these quite large ovarian cysts um
which is where the end of atrocious
grows in the ovaries and my ovarian
function was incredibly low I was kind
of going into this natural menopause at
27 and my Fallopian tubes I think one
was detached and they were just pulled
and just in Ruins basically so I
I had my infertility diagnosis at 27.
goodness and when you look back at that
time what what do you think I mean we
just saw some pictures of you there
obviously in a hospital gown it was a
difficult time yeah I just wish you know
if if I had seen just a poster in a
doctor's surgery or you know a list of
these symptoms I mean when I was
Googling my symptoms all those years ago
they were kind of linking to cervical
cancer you know the irregular periods
pelvic pain pain during sex and I
remember I was going to my GP and I said
you know this isn't right I have all
these symptoms but because of my age I I
was just repeatedly denied smear tests
so you know it can cause a lot of stress
if you're not aware of endometriosis
which is why I'm incredibly grateful to
work with such a big brand like Holland
and Barrett who kind of put my story out
on their digital screens with their
Women's Wellness brand parlor to just
bring that to the High Street because if
I'd seen that I mean you would have
absolutely and there are new drugs
trials not that you you know that's
particularly your area of expertise but
what you can talk to us about is the
impact that has on young women when they
don't know what's happening to their
bodies and other people don't seem to
know either
um we've got better
not particularly I mean I think I see it
every day because you know through
social media and things I follow a lot
of people around endometriosis but
there's still a lot of people that
haven't heard of it or you know don't
know the symptoms I'll go for lunch with
a group of women who I may have never
met before and a lot of them well what
is that you know and it's it's difficult
I mean I remember just two or three
years ago I was going to the hospital
with these endometriosis flare-ups which
were so debilitating I was having to go
to hospital and I would come across
different doctors who would say I'm
sorry I don't really know much about
this goodness well hopefully these new
drug trials will help in in the path to
discovering more about endometriosis so
other young women don't have to go
through what you did it's great to talk
to you thank you for talking to us this
morning much appreciated thank you
apparently it's going to snow today
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
Northerly flow making it very cold with
widespread overnight Frost mild air
preceded by snow and rain will spread
from the south later this week looking
out the window it's snowing a little
tiny bit here in London
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
check this out These Guys these little
guys are not just bumbling around
scientists have discovered that bees can
learn to solve puzzles by watching more
experienced peers these bees trained to
open a puzzle box containing sugar who
then pass this knowledge onto the rest
of their colony it must mean that they
are the
bees knees
or the business I think bee's knees is
better what do you think
um before the break we were talking to
the Home Secretary Suella bravaman she
told me about the government's new
legislation to tackle small boats
migration
we're not breaking the law and no
government representative has said that
we're breaking the law in fact we've
made it very clear that we believe we're
in compliance with all of our
International obligations for example
the refugee convention the European
conventional human rights uh other other
conventions to which we are subject but
what's important is that we do need to
take uh compassionate but necessary and
fair measures now because there are
people who are dying to try and get here
they are breaking our laws they are
abusing the generosity of the British
people
what she couldn't do is tell me when
people will be deported whether there
will be deported to Rwanda when that
will happen and detention centers in the
meantime when will they be built or
reopened couldn't tell me that either
stay tuned
[Music]